[Musique]
la représentation des provinces est
vraiment avec un certain niveau de sérieux
exclusivement professionnel pour les femmes
ou est-il possible de le lier
exquis quelles sont les mesures ou quoi
diffère entre eux
Qui est notre responsable des infections?
annoncer officiellement l'approbation de
la pratique de la boxe féminine du pays
Cela a été un long processus d'analyse de
étudier les évaluations sur le terrain
techniques et dans le domaine de la santé
praticiens systématiques ce
sport
[Musique]
Cette nouvelle m'a fait du bien parce que
Je l'attendais depuis longtemps
Je veux avoir une vie sportive comme
boxer et faire de mon mieux
une médaille pour laquelle je vais me sacrifier
une médaille Et si à l'avenir
les femmes ici à Cuba peuvent faire
professionnel ravi aussi
tout va bien et oui bien représenter
mon pays à des jeux olympiques dans un
Pan américain dans un Amérique centrale à voir
si nous pouvons contribuer avec autant de réalisations
Qu'ont fait les hommes pour contribuer
tant de médailles pour la boxe et
Délégation cubaine
justificatif